we all know I'm not nice no no you're
not nice either today we have Forrest
self-identified garbage people and we're
putting them to the test to find out how
garbage they really are let's meet our
contestants
hi my name is Al and I love flavored
ramen I'm Francesca and I love yelling
in public I'm Erin and I drank wine like
its water hi my name is Sarah and I
ain't Doritos for dinner to end a hug
you usually a wait for the other person
to move B tap their shoulder twice see I
don't hug yeah probably a hugger when I
get a little tipsy I hug my friends and
everybody loves it and they always make
a big deal about it but then like the
next day I'm like oh please don't don't
hug me I do the two cheek kisses thing
if you're into that very French very
turkey and gosh have you ever forgotten
your parents birthday eh
yes and I felt so bad B no C yes and it
will probably happen again I love you
mom I've almost forgotten my parents
birthday but eh I don't think I ever
have we love you just because we don't
remember your birthday doesn't mean we
don't love you you're insanely hungry
the only food left in the fridge is your
roommates lasagna do you a leave it
untouched be cut off a tiny piece or C
demolish it oh my god is it this
specific lasagna because if it is then
that's mine definitely it's already cut
into yeah it's gonna be easy to do a
secret slice yeah be a self-advocate you
know if you need that food take that
food I'm gonna be sneaky about it I'm
gonna take just a little bit so that
they don't notice it but enough where
I'm satisfied it was gonna go in the
trash anyway you're doing them a favor
when you say I'll be right there you
really mean a I'm still in bed B I'm
about 15 minutes away
see I'm not coming
it's like it's a or B I've done both
always late but I don't want my friends
to be mad at me so I act like I'm on
time I'm perpetually late I try to blame
it on things I'm like oh it's because
I'm gay I should be on time for things
and there's not I don't want to get
there and have you be later than me this
is bad garbage there's like good garbage
you now must choose between your
favorite healthy snack and your favorite
unhealthy snack so this is really hard
not even a question are you kidding me
this is obviously I would probably go
with this right now
not because I'm a paragon of Health you
know honestly just ask me at all this
food sorry Francesca I consider my
eating habits to be pulling trash I'm
waiting for the day of my metabolisms
open the gonna revolt
I'm so happy you know trash people need
their vitamins too it's not like popcorn
that's one like corn kernels and corners
like a vegetable so yeah works for me
these trash humans have now taken the
test now I will calculate the results
that's mine I don't want to other you're
doing them a favor the results are in
not all garbage is created equal but
you're all beautiful trash humans and my
eyes congratulations everyone you all
win this Bill's correct see mom I won
something if your garbage should be
proud of yourself that's who you are I'm
sorry but I don't plan on changing
you're supposed to act how you know you
are on the inside and one day people
will recognize you for what that is well
that's all folks we know we're not alone
let us know how trashed you are in the
comments below
[Music]